c'est que moi je suis prêt à faire un
essai beaucoup de personnes ne sont
peut-être pas forcément disponibles pour
faire un essai sur place directe la tuer
manche du mondial
elle a fait un essai trois semaines
trois semaines en tant qu'hôtesse de 4
gratuit
malheureusement à bâtir la paix sur lui
parce qu'elle était malade une fois à
l'intérieur a été direct avec elle et
delilah lost est longue
c'est du jeu c'est oui je comprends ça
on peut dire c'est dégueulasse et
ehrhoff je sais je savais quand lui et
je sais je sais je pense aussi que c'est
dégueulasse
on a mis son sont assises sur le cd elle
a embauché maintenant grâce à sa pauvre
ouvrier
on est dans la vie active amis on n'est
pas dans les genoux de travail mérite
salaire
c'est dur de savoir quand même qu'on
travaille sur cette piste
tu prenais auquel est moche je sais que
je suis pas extra fasciné par l'argent
mais ça cerveau quand même cette fille
n'a jamais fait de vente
ça reste toujours un plus et puis la
boutique est très connu donc ça va bien
sur le cv
foxy bien sur le cv